well it's funny as we as we talk about
it there are like ones that I then they
come back to mind oh yeah right we did
that right yeah you know like I was
saying yeah I was thinking like we drove
an ice cream truck around that was a
great one you know and I and I hadn't
thought about that in years and it just
was in my head when you were talking
about the camping one because yeah it
was around that time yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and again it was just like a
Saturday and there wasn't like a lot of
ideas it was just we'll see what happens
yeah go out and around that time you did
one where you guys literally backstage
had a map of the tri-state area oh yeah
and it was some college oh no it was
some little nowhere South Centerville
yeah that's on the list
we've covered everything on the list
yeah yeah that one was and then you just
went there kind of that was a great way
to pick a remote that was very Huell
Houser because we just kind of were like
hey there's some people in their yard
fell in your pool yeah I think yeah we
don't have a pool that was a very
sometimes those could get because you
felt the pressure of like I gotta make
sure yeah I gotta make some television I
know I I also would think one I should
say like nothing happening is good for a
beat maybe but right something else no
you yeah something has to happen
I was just remembering and this is this
was a remote but just it was in a comedy
bit
um
and often things would be presented to
us uh
you know widget you know so and so is
common to town and they're going to be
signing books you want to do anything at
the book signing or something so
somebody said somebody came in and was
like Hulk Hogan and Randy Savage Macho
Man Randy Savage are gonna be across the
river at like uh a book a marina no
there was a boat they've done it again
at a marina in Hoboken across the river
like and and they're like do you want to
do it and it's like oh I gotta think of
something for Hulk Hogan and Randy
Savage and so I came up with this idea
that the devil appears and it was John H
John Benjamin uh voice of Bob's Burgers
and Archer yeah um and he was the devil
and presented me with my heart's desire
if I would sign my soul over to him
and I signed it over and Conan's like
what are you doing and then I go you
know and I'm like bring it on and then
it just turns out that uh my heart's
desire is driving around in a speedboat
firing guns with Hulk Hogan and Randy
Savage firing guns in the air that's
really cool and so we went across we
went to shoot that and
God bless Bill Tall who has passed on
yes but probably our prop Master uh he
got he he got he drove the van which he
didn't need to drive the van they said
I'm gonna drive the van and he drove
through like the Garment District on the
west side going 60 miles an hour just so
fast cutting Corners to where like I'm
sitting in the passenger van and if
there hadn't been glass in the window I
could have kissed a a person standing on
the corner oh my God cutting it so close
people going whoa yeah
smacking side view mirrors
you know as we're driving down yeah we
get out we get up in a hurry
we would go you know we went out and
shot the thing and we had a bunch of you
know we'd always overthink it and bring
a bunch of props and stuff yeah and
rubber chicken Bill had a little kid's
fishing rod and for some reason and he
was being real casual with with Hulk
Hogan and Randy Savage and Randy Savage
was fine they've been he somehow he got
on this thing that he lost the fishing
rod and he got on this thing that Hulk
Hogan had taken it and he kept going hey
Hulk where's my fishing rod you know
it's a kid's fishing rod you can't use
it yeah yeah come on Hulk give me you
know yeah Hulk where's my fishing rod
like teasing him and and Hulk at first
is like hahaha and then he's like no no
seriously where's my fishing rod
and then which you know would know to
like back off for a while and then dive
in again like it come on seriously I
need that fishing rod we're gonna we
might want to do it for a bit you know
all right so we finished the thing and
and it's time for Hulk and Randy Savage
to go sign autographs in the boat show
Pavilion we get back in the van Bill
insists on driving again as and
someone's like oh we someone else can
drive uh but like Bill's like no no I
got I'll drive I got the keys we pull
out of the place but then he stops in
front of the Pavilion goes hold on I
gotta get something gets out runs in
runs in for a few minutes comes back out
gets in the van and I said well I said
what did you forget I said you didn't
bring anything he goes like I just want
to go back in and ask Hulk for the
fishing rod one more time
he really did I'm doing a bit no and he
used it in his next bout on WWE yeah but
he said he said he he said like because
he was signing autographs he goes like
and yeah he goes he goes that time he he
looked a little hot
it's like the last time he did he looked
a little mad I pushed it too far yeah
serious ball bust yeah I know that's
great yeah I do too